hello good morning everyone
my name is Damien Griffin Appy to talk
today about the emerging technologies
and specifically for the management of
chronic diseases
I am magnificent bosses
very nice place very nice done a lot of
great monuments also the foods and so on
we have also very nice Hospital that's
my hospital in sand
bottles clink niversity sonic and we are
renewing the hospital with a project for
2025 there is also the project on going
for institution for the switch to a new
electronic medical record system by the
mid June 2020 so coming soon that just
illustrating that the there is a lot of
change ongoing in the healthcare system
and the ecosystem at large is changing
transforming transforming because of the
economical pressure transforming because
of the burden of the chronic disease
more and more patient unfortunately our
candidates for having chronic disease
even if it could be not communicated
communicable or communicable there is
the change in the age pyramid we the
so-called silver tsunami more elderly
people also more pawns of ecology and
the ecosystem is changing also because
everywhere all over the world we have a
shortage in the healthcare resources and
ecosystem is changing also because of
the technology new emerging technology
digit
technology transforming the way we are
practicing and if you are going to the
Internet just an example solely for the
the publicity Amazon just for example is
working on new healthcare services the
example of diabetes where they are
singing to have an app and a sensor to
measure and play a role in the diabetes
care management is an illustration of
new player coming to the field of health
care or a laboratory test
diabetes is a great example to
illustrate this impact of emerging
technology if you look to the number for
the world there is more than 40 425
million people suffering of diabetes
it's around 1 on 11 and unfortunately
there is about 1.5 million days higher
cost to diabetes
big impact unfortunately big numbers
huge mobility huge mortality there is
the complication of diabetes as we know
that will also impact the quality of
life of the patient the need for care
there is a cost also if you consider the
cardiovascular complications for
diabetes if you consider the kidney
dysfunction related to diabetes the I
the diabetes food for example so
important in those patient to go for the
early risk estimation of complication
and try to prevent in contrast to to
care so prevention is needed and the new
technology could participate the
prevention initiatives if we talk of
emerging technology
we have to talk about digital elph and
digital elph
is no the self largest industry in the
European health sector just after the
pharmaceutical and the medical device
the number of spectacular more than
[Music]
300,000 app available on the market
the number of variables balance steps
counter is also increasing the smart
smartwatches are an example we have
different domains that we could discuss
the clinical or medical information
systems there is the telemedicine direct
mobile elf and there is the data science
the science of machine learning is
something also impacting the way we are
and we will manage chronic diseases the
the remote monitoring is something that
has changed clearly in the field of
diabetes we have sensors that could be
used to continuously monitoring the the
glucose and the patient-physician will
see the continuous data from the glucose
the patient will see the number of I Pau
I pair will be able to anticipate some
episode of I probably see Mia and will
be empowered in the management of it
this the platform are also dynamic
interaction with the diabetes care that
could recommend to the patient early
visits or some majority could adapt and
this connectivity this remote monitoring
as I mentioned is more facilitated by
the
we're rebels there is more and more
we're rebels and according to this
French study there is top where rebels
that are used smartwatches glucometer
the tension the the balance really tools
useful for the patient of suffering for
chronic disease though the weight is
important to monitor in some condition
like diabetes or heart failure for
example and it's easy to that's an
example where you could easily have the
view for the patient allowing the
monitoring of the glucose a1c estimation
grab some gamified coaching and the
connection with the diabetes care where
you have vision of the different patient
to to manage and zoom on the one who
could present the digital phenotype
which is with an increased risk new or
reasons also through the telehealth
because the connectivity is there so
opening the the possibility for virtual
appointment virtual consultation the
patient could have access also to
certified
educators be trained or educate through
video conference session change the
behaviors by being empower and there is
also the telemedicine or the
teledermatology for screening of some
retinopathy so the diabetes more hyper
connected or dynamic or real-time
connection we are as specialists in
laboratory medicine also involved in
this continuous integration and
management of data
and we have control center where we will
we already able to monitor for point of
care on instrument in the laboratory but
also soon for sensor and that's
mandatory to have this control to be
sure that we have the necessary quality
control to see the training of the user
the competency of the people using the
smart connecting devices so and behind
that say hello we have some warning
please do something to the action on
time action with these new systems new
technology we transform the way we are
dealing with outcome there is new
outcomes because of the emerging
technology because the connected device
and we have the opportunity by the the
prevention to improve some outcomes be
more anticipative to some complication
and I think for this prevention needs
early identification of the patient at
risk through the blood tests and the
integration of new biomarkers we play a
role the example that I truly study with
valuate new biomarker gdf 15 and the
fibroblast growth factor of 23 and they
were related to mortality in type 2
diabetes we know that these two factors
are also related to advanced
cardiovascular even in population like
hypertensive subject or type 2 diabetes
so the integration of Lima Germans of
these new biomarkers might contribute to
these prevention initiatives and
leveraging more data that we could in
great that's what I call the power of
the data new DNA and we are contributed
for that there is several source of data
the the laboratory information system
and the laboratory data data clearly a
big bunch of this data because of the
number of requests because of the number
of tests if you consider the omics
genomics proteomics that will help to
guide decision or more accurately
estimate risk diagnosis data machine
learning new trends there is also the
trends for distributed load so you can
if you have an algorithm relying on on
the data you can distribute that to some
remote spot in hospitals in care
facilities and the model will integrate
the on-site data will and will be more
and more accurate because of this
learning on the real world data so
machine learning data science to have
more early risk estimation distributed
learning to make the evolution of the
algorithm learning for clinical and real
practices data integration is more real
than ever because we have also the the
cloud for the l3 Co so it's easy from
different spot which could be the
primary care the hospital care or the
patient himself with sensor to transfer
the data to the cloud integrate and get
more option for the to get the clinical
decision support on the data so because
of the the computing power because of
the cloud computing power
this is becoming real we all but we need
to carefully drive this if we want to
have the Augmented laboratory medicine
based on the data integration the
framework need to integrate the
challenge of ethics data privacy the the
the regulation the legal framework and
oh can we finance this new technology
and new data and there is some European
country with already thought financing
for digital application of data side we
have also the ability through the new
technology to change the the behavior of
the patient literacy more educated and
patient will be more aware of the risk
of the disease so we can win some
quality of life and some thyme and some
complication the changing ecosystem mean
also that the patient and the citizen
are already going to Internet to track
the symptoms track the treatment so they
are user of the web-based interface and
know that that's the other trend the
users for the mobile health technology
so they will use the mobile health
application to monitor the disease get
tips and tricks for the education so the
transition is ongoing and that will be
helpful to improve the literacy of the
patient this image to illustrate that in
Europe at least 50% of the population is
not literate enough missing information
of the disease symptoms and it's also an
opportunity to educate
the scare forces to new technologies
coming from the from the lab so emerging
technologies of playing a keyboard for
the improvement of literacy and the
education to the diabetes type 2 for
example the ability to have the food
monitoring dietary counseling option
number one more opportunities rich get
Impala medicated patient also the case
for patient with diabetes type 2 for
example medication reminders warning for
some potential interaction and the
prescription refill reminders are also
opportunity offer by the new digital
surrounding and we have a groups social
networking social group to empower the
patient they will discuss in between
them important tips and tricks
opportunity also to give message there
is new treatments there is new clinical
trials so low allowing by these new
digital and emerging technology we are
changing also a bit the way we are
practicing we are living in smart
environment meaning that we are shifting
from recent holiday scare to something
which is more distributed integrated
more and more connectivity between
hospital care primary care or pemmican
hospital care on care more use or more
integration of resources more our best
shows of associates that are connected
interactive more multidisciplinary
exchange also so the ecosystem more
interdisciplinary more dynamic I am
convinced yeah going to this important
multidisciplinary collaborative could
collaborative care model where we have
different player the physician
laboratorians the pharmacist the patient
the helpers that will interact in a more
connected in terrible environment we
need to take care to train the
healthcare forces of two more the the
curriculum we need to take care that
they will acquire these new skills for
digital tools emerging technology if we
want to make the best use of the
technology
we of course have multiple challenges to
face what is the real added value of
this new technology
are they interoperable enough that's a
very important question at the API not
locked
what is the validation fine work for
this new technology laboratorians will
play the whole the validation of the new
lab devices will tell a laboratory
medicine practices more advice through
the digital channel challenge for the
regulation challenge for the financing
and we will have financing if we are
able to demonstrate the
cost-effectiveness of the system we have
fortunately some recommendation this
example of the draft guideline for the
ethical practices of artificial
intelligence at the European scale
cost-effectiveness of course what is the
business model very different element in
the literature showing that digital care
should could be cost effective what will
be the way to finance it will it be
state finance there is example in
Denmark Germany with digital
application reimbursed by the governor
or will it be out-of-pocket patient paid
that question that we need to answer or
will it be an eye brain model I don't
know we will face also the question of
the democratization of the access to the
technology we need to take care that the
cost will not be too much for device
that could be helpful for the world
community so that's the the cold market
analysis and make sure that the majority
over the world will be able to use the
technology and we need to support the
emerging countries to to use this new
technology the cost will be an issue
three girls are coming the example of
the 5g which will make this data digital
world more efficient more faster more
interoperable that's clear I thing I
think that we should be optimistic on
these promises from the emerging
technology of course there is the famous
Gardner hype cycle where there is this
phase of stimulation there is of this
faith of Jesus disillusion integrating
the different challenges but there is
delight coming and we are reaching the
plateau of productivity that will come
that is coming at least in already some
countries so be be positive but we are
also the important gatekeepers for this
transition of technology so it's not the
technology alone but it's the use the
best use of the technology by the human
best use of resources and we will
succeed and provide new
Digital enhanced service thanks a lot
for your attention we will have a great
lecture from and soon and same for the
boards for the year opportunity thank
you very much hello everyone thank you
dr. Grusin for that very interesting and
exciting and so I guess it is now my
turn and it's my pleasure to be part of
this panel and to thank lab roots for
inviting me to speak about mobile health
and environment and point of care
testing my name is anitha's airy
I live in Edmonton Alberta Canada I work
for Alberta precision laboratories and I
am the no secretary point of care
testing medical lead I am also a
corresponding member of the IFC C
Committee on mobile house and bio
engineering and Laboratory Medicine
and I'm a clinical associate professor
at the University of Alberta and so
today I am going to talk about
point-of-care testing in mobile health
environments with a specific focus on
errors and what kind of errors may be
typical in these environments and what
we can do to try to reduce these types
of errors and so my talk is going to
consist of four sections I'm going to
talk briefly about error classification
in portal care testing in general then
I'm going to move on very briefly to how
I define mobile health for the purposes
of this presentation I'm then going to
talk about opportunities for point of
care testing errors in mobile health
environments and I'm going to conclude
my presentation by talking a little bit
about risk mitigation strategies that we
can put in place to help reduce these
types of errors
so I'd like to start by talking a little
bit about errors and point-of-care
testing in general and a good place to
start is the error classification that
was developed by dr. Charles cost back
in the 2000s 2000 the classification
system that he developed was slightly
modified a couple of years later by my
own colleagues and so the resulting
error classification system has
illustrated in the table here and the
way that this table works is that
point-of-care testing is divided into
three different phases the pre analytic
phase the analytic phase and post
analytic phase and then on the
right-hand side you can see some of the
more I guess important errors that
doctor cast and Meyer and his colleagues
identified in each of these phases so
the pre analytic phase was broken down
into and four important parts test
ordering patient and specimen
identification specimen collection
specimen evaluation before you actually
do the testing so this is for things
like specimen quality including
hemolysis like pinyin icterus
or or any other kind of specimen quality
issues the analytic phase was broken
down into calibration of the method so
for example if there is a calibration
that's due and the end user forgets to
do that correctly that would be an error
specimen and reiated interaction with
each other the actual generation of the
result and then result validation and so
result validation for example would
include running of quality controls
periodically or other performance
indicators to make sure that the result
that is being produced by your point of
care device is actually accurate
and the last phase that was developed
for this era classification system was
the post analytic phase and most of the
things in this category relates to the
report that contains the result so
formatting of the reports critical value
reporting any other important result
reporting so for example if you have
some sort of panel and there are certain
types of results there are more
important than others maybe there might
be a system in place to report those
more important results and report
recording and retrieval so for example
if you have a device that gives you a
paper printout and that printout is
manually entered into a patient chart
but a mistake is made during the entry
and so the final paper chart does not
accurately reflect the original result
that would be an error as well and so
this was this classification system was
developed in the early 2000s I think for
purposes of mobile health we can add two
other categories in here that become
important
so one would be infection control and
then the other category would have to do
with privacy security data integrity and
transmission and of course infection
control becomes particularly important
when we start using a single device on
multiple patients and this would
certainly be the case for mobile health
environments where we might have access
to one or two devices at most but we use
it on multiple patients and then of
course for the purposes of mobile health
and the whole piece about data integrity
and transmission and privacy and
security becomes very important as well
and there can be errors made in this
phase as well
so I'd like to talk a little bit about
what we currently know about errors
improve care testing so I just mentioned
the classification system that was
developed but what do we actually know
about the types of errors that occur in
point-of-care testing and then
specifically in mobile health
environments so I like to liken our
knowledge on this topic to this map here
where you can see that parts of the map
are very well explored very detailed in
terms of cities that exist and features
that exist and then the top left part of
the map is very detailed and we really
don't know very much about that part of
North America and so the things that we
do know about errors in point of care
testing come from a number of key
studies that were published by different
point of care groups who perform quality
assurance programs for their various
point of care testing programs in their
hospitals and so the key here is is that
most of these studies were done in
hospitals there are almost no studies
done in mobile health environments
mostly because of the recent order I
guess
the young nature of mobile health but
what we do know from hospital
environments is we have a good idea of
average error rates and but what I mean
by averages is that a lot of these
studies did audits of the different
point of care programs looked at error
rates but they averaged the error rates
over different types of point of care
programs so let's say they had a blood
gas analysis program they had a manual
urinalysis program they looked at the
error rates in all of those and just
averaged amounts so we have one number
instead of knowing the error rate for
your analysis programs or the error rate
for blood gas analysis programs we do
have a comprehensive list of quality
indicators and these are based on
quality considerations on different
regulatory and accreditation
requirements and then also on that error
classification system that I showed you
in the previous slide we also have tools
for data collection so we have error
reporting systems which are systems
where either the end users or a point of
care groups can log errors that have
occurred for record-keeping purposes and
also what the outcome of the error was
we also have in-person visits which
sometimes called audits these are also
also really great tools to identify
parts of the point of care testing
process that are being done incorrectly
and then nowadays we have data
management software and this is becoming
more important we're able to connect
point of care devices into point of care
middleware and then look in the
middleware to retrieve data and to
analyze that to identify possible trends
or patterns that we may want to
troubleshoot and the last piece of
information
we know which is lat in-person
assessments otherwise known as audits do
reduce error rate it's so it's important
to monitor air but it's also importance
to end-users through in-person visits it
gives us an opportunity to establish
relationships also to talk about things
that end users may not be doing
correctly and they're received much
better than if we just send an email or
just some sort of note now in terms of
what we don't know there are quite a few
things so I mentioned that most of the
studies that exist to date about errors
in front of care testing or in hospital
environments so we don't really have a
good understanding of errors in other
environments such as in mobile health we
also don't really have a good big
breakdown as I mentioned before about
different error rates for different
types of point of care testing so are
the error rates for manual urinalysis
different than for an automated blood
gas analyzer we just don't know we don't
really have also a standardized
threshold for acceptable error rates so
for example what's an acceptable rate
for competency if 90% of our end users
are competent is that acceptable does it
need to be 100% different groups I think
will use different acceptable thresholds
but there really isn't a standardized
number that's available we also don't
really have a good feel for the rate of
adverse events due to point of care
testing errors and while we do have a
list of comprehensive quality indicators
we don't really know which one of those
are the most important and this again
comes down to understanding error rates
for the different types of point of care
testing programs so it may be that if
certain types of errors are more
prominent in one program than another
may be that we may need different
quality
the indicators for that program versus
other programs and we just don't know
the reason that this is important this
is because it's point-of-care testing
grows it becomes more challenging to
monitor all of the quality indicators
for every single program usually most
point-of-care groups are understaffed
and so we really have to identify the
quality indicators that are the most
important for each program in order to
utilize the time of our staff
efficiently and then finally two other
important things that we don't really
have very good ideas about is what are
the most accurate and effective tools
for data acquisition so I mentioned a
number of different tools that we have
available but each of those tools has
limitations so for example error
reporting systems are often voluntary
and so it's not always clear whether all
of the errors make it into those
reporting systems or not so they may be
one piece of the puzzle but they may not
be the best tool to use by themselves to
monitor errors and then the last piece
is about frequency of monitoring so
again we have different approaches
depending on the point of care group
that does the monitoring some groups do
it on a weekly basis some groups do it
once a year
some groups do it once a month we really
don't know what frequency is the most
optimal so it would be good to get more
information about each of these
considerations so next I would like to
move on to a definition of mobile health
since this presentation is about errors
in mobile health it's important that we
all have the same understanding of what
mobile health is so this is actually a
tricky question and I will show you here
why so these are three different
definitions from the three different
professional organizations for what they
consider mobile health so you can see
that in the first definition
the World Health Organization defines
mobile health as the use of mobile
wireless technologies for Public Health
the second definition from the World
Medical Association it's actually quite
similar so it also refers to the use of
mobile devices to provide healthcare and
you can see that the third definition
which is from the committee that I am a
part of also refers to the use of mobile
technologies to provide healthcare so
these definitions from different
professional organizations are actually
quite similar another thing that's
similar across these definitions is that
there isn't a very clear definition of
the type of health care that's provided
with the use of mobile technologies and
you know I wasn't there when these
professional organizations drafted these
definitions but I imagine that may be
part of the reason why they don't have a
concrete definition of the type of
healthcare is this because mobile house
is really in its infancy and so we don't
know how pervasive it's going to be as
it becomes more available now the
challenge is is that even though these
mobile health definitions by
professional organizations are quite
similar they're not universally accepted
and so you can see here a definition
that I found from a healthcare product
company and so they they still include
in their definition the use of mobile
technologies to provide healthcare but
in this definition the mobile
technologies and the healthcare is
limited to the patient so the healthcare
provider is completely eliminated from
this definition so really this company
refers to mobile health in the context
of consumer technologies and then if you
look at this definition
which is from a paper that talks about
providing a tree antiretroviral therapy
in rural Mozambique this definition does
not mention what the mobile technologies
at all so here they refer to mobile
health clinics and these being
four-wheel-drive trucks that are able to
reach isolated destinations and are
equipped to provide comprehensive health
service so in this definition the idea
of mobile health is not really related
to mobile technology rather it's related
to the movement of health care from a
central location out into the
centralized location that's closer to
the patient's location so for my
presentation I'm going to define mobile
health as a type of health delivery
model that incorporates three different
features so one there's a geographical
separation between an individual and one
or more members of the healthcare team
and this separation can be hundreds of
kilometres but it could also be just a
few kilometers so for example if a
patient is in a hospital but let's say
the physician that consults with the
patient's healthcare team is at another
hospital in the city so that could also
be mobile house now next the next
condition is is that the separation
between the individual and members of
the healthcare team poses a barrier to
accessing timely and appropriate care in
traditional medical institutions and the
third condition is is that mobile
technologies either reduced a barrier or
they have the potential to do so in the
future and so what this implies is is
that there may be programs right now
they don't necessarily use mobile
technologies or use them in a limited
setting but if these programs could
greatly benefit from mobile technologies
were they implemented in the future then
they
fulfilled this condition as well and so
my experience is mostly with programs
that fulfill both the first two points
and then with regards to the third point
most of the programs that I have
experience with have only limited mobile
technologies or none at all right now
but I think it's important to think
about these types of settings as well
because I think that they can really
tell us a lot and we can learn a lot
about what is necessary to have in place
once mobile technologies to become so
commonplace in healthcare that they are
part of these programs all right so next
I would like to move on to point of care
errors point of care testing errors in
these types of mobile health
environments and I'm going to talk about
four specific opportunities for errors
there are other ones as well but due to
limited time I'm going to focus on these
four so opportunities due to
environmental stresses opportunities due
to suboptimal operating conditions
opportunities due to inadequate
infection control and opportunities
because of limitations in mobile
infrastructure so let's talk about
environmental stresses first so the
issue with mobile health environments is
is that the point of care devices and
reagents in these environments may be
adversely affected by things like
extreme temperatures vibrations impact
shark humidity moisture pressure dirt
and dust and other types of
environmental stresses that are not
necessarily seen in for example a
hospital setting and so as an example I
want to show you here three different
studies that looks at the impact of
temperature variations and temperature
extremes on performance of point of care
testing reagents and so the first study
looked at the performance of cardio
and I and BMP testing in what is short
term temperature elevations and they
found that these types of elevations led
to false negative results the next study
looked at short-term exposure of glucose
test strips and mirrors to high
temperatures and humidity and they found
that these types of environmental
stresses produced measurement biases as
high as 33 milligrams per deciliter or
1.8 millimoles per liter which is quite
a significant amount depending on the
initial starting Lucas of the patient
and the last study looked at infectious
disease testing specifically dengue
rapid diagnostic tests and they stored
them for six months at tropical
temperatures similar to what they would
expect to store them in in real-life
operation and while they found that
these temperatures did not affect
performance of a test called an s-1
antigen test they did find that it
affected the IgM test performance and
that this dust show lower rear
reactivity was selected samples so what
are the take-home messages from these
studies and an important take-home
message is that you can't make
generalizations about the impact of
these types of temperature variations on
how it's going to affect your
point-of-care reagents and so it's
really actually necessary to as part of
your analytical validation to examine
the performance of your assays under the
environmental conditions that are going
to be present in the intended setting in
order to understand what kind of
performance issues you may see with your
reagents and so here the error potential
with these environmental stresses is is
that in many cases point of care groups
or end users will not thoroughly
validate the impact of such stresses on
their point
testing systems and so that and when
they do use them out in the field
there's a potential for them to be using
devices and reagents that have
questionable integrity and because of
that they produce results that are
either inaccurate or they may not
produce results at all in critical
situations and then end users are stuck
they may have to do some other
workarounds which can introduce errors
as well now in addition to environmental
stresses suboptimal
operating conditions can also be a
problem in mobile health environments
and specifically these types of
environments may not have a well-lit
area where the testing can be performed
they may not have a dry area it may be
noisy so all calm and quiet environment
is gone there may not be a stationary
and level surface to do the testing
there may not be adequate power and so
forth so for example for our ice stats
that are used in our province one of the
first pieces of instruction that we have
in the standard operating procedure is
to operate the ice that on a level
surface for the entire period of testing
and so two of our programs that use the
ice that are the Alberta stroke
ambulance which you can see on the left
that's a picture of the inside of the
ambulance and stars which is it's a
private organization nonprofit
organization that is subcontracted by
our provincial health care system so
they both use the eye stats and so I
want you to take a look at the pictures
here and stick about where you see a
level surface here that the staff on
these vehicles and aircraft can use to
put their eye stat for the period of
testing so I don't know if you agree
with me but I don't see too many areas
that are level and
we're an ice that could go so this is
clearly a problem and so the the error
potential that it introduces is that
staff are not able to follow what is
laid out in standard operating
procedures and they're not able to use
the devices and systems in a way that is
really most optimal for use and so this
again either leads to suboptimal results
because the SOPs are not being
completely followed or it may even lead
to staff trying to do work around and
then when they do these workarounds they
may be doing things that they actually
don't know if it's really you know how
what how it impacts the point-of-care
system and the results that are produced
alright next I would like to talk about
inadequate infection control and so
there are quite a few studies available
that suggest that improper disinfection
of shared point of care devices can lead
to the transmission of infection from
one patient to another and there are
particularly good manuscripts published
about this in the area of glucose
testing and the transmission of
hepatitis B from one patient to another
there's also a really good paper which
is the first one I cite on this slide
that documented that about 30% of
glucose meters in hospital environment
are contaminated by blood and so have
the potential to transmit infection from
one patient to another and so because of
this a number of different organizations
have recommended that shared point of
care devices should be cleaned and
disinfected after each use now if we use
point of care devices that are intended
for point of care testing so that's how
they're marketed like an ISTAT or a
glucose meter there are very clear
recommendations from the magnified
sure about how to disinfect and clean
these devices the problem that we run
into in mobile health environments is is
if we start using devices that are
adapted to point-of-care testing so they
weren't specifically made for
point-of-care testing but they're being
adapted for it such as a smartphone
there's usually a lack of guidance on
how these types of devices should be
disinfected in order to achieve complete
and adequate disinfection and I was
curious just what type of information is
available on this so I looked in my own
smartphone user guide and there was
nothing about any type of disinfection
or anything relating to disinfection the
other important piece here is is that if
we try to apply the types of
disinfection that we would use for
devices marketed specifically for point
of care testing it's really unclear how
long these these other types of devices
like smartphones would last so if I wipe
a smartphone down with a hydrogen
peroxide containing wipe and let it
stand wet for a couple of minutes and I
do this repeatedly just how long is that
smartphone going to last and this is
really not there at the moment and so
the error potential here is of course
that with these devices that are adapted
for point of care testing and mobile
health that we do not adequately
disinfect them and then that this can
then lead to transmission of infection
from one patient to another all right so
the last opportunity for error that I
would like to talk about today is
related to limitations and mobile
infrastructure and so mobile
infrastructure has many components and
we have basic systems and data sources
which are required to have the mobile
data available you have gateways which
are needed for secure data exchange
between your source systems and your
devices and applications
you have enterprise mobility management
which is important for being able to
manage users of the devices and the apps
and then you have the devices that the
user interfaces themselves and so
there's actually not a whole lot that
we're able to say about the limitations
of these in a mobile health environment
because we're actually still learning to
understand how to best utilize this type
of technology within more structured
settings such as hospitals and I'll talk
about an example here to illustrate my
point so this is a publication that came
out this year and it's talked about an
application that was developed at a
university medical center for the entry
of patient vital signs at the bedside
and so the idea was developed by a nurse
and a nurse manager and they wanted to
do this because what was happening in
their institution was that they would
take these vital signs down and a piece
of paper in the patient bedside and then
later when they had time they would go
to a computer and manually enter the
data and so they thought that if they
had an application on either a
smartphone or some sort of tablet that
they were able to use right when they
were at the patient bedside this would
change and improve their workflow and
would treat minor so again a nurse in a
nurse managed the ICO developed by the
IT team and the nurse team they then
released the in-house app after a couple
of rounds of feedback and optimization
but the in-house app once it was
released was actually not very popular
so there were some clinical areas where
the uptick was only 10% and after some
investigation they found out that the
app was unsuccessful because of
limitations in the mobile infrastructure
so for example when the devices were
switching between wireless access points
when nurses were basically going from
one spot to another they would lose
connection with the Wi-Fi and so they
were missing data entries because during
those hiccups or do those last
connections data was not being
transmitted into the EMR and because of
this the nursing groups would then start
to modify that workflow to get around
these hiccups so for example if there
were certain rooms where they knew that
the Wi-Fi was better than others then
they would start assigning rooms to
certain nurses so a room that had a good
Wi-Fi setup for example would be
assigned to a nurse who was very keen on
using this app whereas a room that had
more poor Wi-Fi would be assigned to
nerds who didn't necessarily want to use
this app that much whereas before they
did have these kinds of room assignments
and so they found that these workflow
modifications that they did in order to
get around these hiccups in the Wi-Fi
they actually led to a much more complex
workflow that they had previously and
then in addition to that there were also
some missing functionality in the apps
because of the technical limitations and
data security that was imposed by the
organization and then not related to
mobile infrastructure but to the
infection control piece that I talked
about in my previous slides there were
also challenges and properly
disinfecting the tablets that they were
using and so all of this led to the app
having a really poor uptake amongst the
clinical staff even though it was the
original idea was from clinical staff
and it was developed in collaboration
with clinical staff and so really I
think what this shows and how it relates
to the mobile health setting is that
there are there are many error
potentials related to limitations in
mobile infrastructure
and it's going to relate to the
particular limitation but because we
don't completely understand how to best
utilize this type of technology even in
a more structured setting it's difficult
to predict in advance what type of
errors will be made in the mobile house
setting which is even less structured
and has more challenges with mobile
infrastructure all right so I would like
to finish my talk about point-of-care
testing and error rates in mobile house
settings by just discussing a few risk
mitigation strategies that we can put in
place today in order to work on having a
really robust point-of-care testing
program in mobile house settings in the
future so I think first and foremost
it's really important to think about the
point-of-care program and to really
evaluate it for error potential and to
use the LSI guideline EP 23 a laboratory
quality control based on risk management
to help develop a quality assurance
program that addresses the key areas for
errors and puts in place quality
assurance practices for those for those
points and this we can do today I think
that we can also more thoroughly
characterize existing point-of-care
testing systems under the conditions
that are relevant to mobile health so I
think previously both manufacturers and
supportive care groups and a clinical
groups used to characterize point of
care testing systems within hospital
settings and less so in other settings
but I think now that mobile health is
growing it's really important for
manufacturers to start really validating
these in these mobile health settings
that may have extreme temperatures or
other environmental stressors and and
also for clinical groups and point of
care groups when they do their own
in-house
nation to start validating devices under
conditions that are relevant to these
settings I think that it's important to
start developing and commercially
marketing accessories for point of care
testing that are helpful in mobile
health so for example we're still
lacking a simple and cost-effective
storage container for point of care
devices that helps to protect them from
a lot of these environmental stressors
that I mentioned and so point-of-care
testing groups and clinical groups are
really left to figure out on their own
some sort of workaround for this and
finally I think going forward it will be
important to design novel point of care
testing systems with mobile house in
mind and with an understanding of the
key challenges of mobile health
environments and designing systems that
are able to perform robustly in these
types of environments and with that I
will finish my talk if you have any
questions about any of my presentation
or would like to discuss point of care
testing in mobile house please feel free
to email me at an advisory at alberta
public labs that CA thank you